The United States is
the most refrigerated country in the world.
We have more than a hundred million cubic meters
of thermal control.
That means nothing to me. But once I did the math...
That is actually not so much smaller than the Arctic.
So basically we built a third Pole
for our food to live in. Which is incredible.
And then, all these separate refrigerated spaces
are connected by a cold chain.
So you end up with this sort of seamless
monument of engineered winter.
And the thing that happened to me is
I realized, I'd been writing about food for
a decade at this point
when I first turned my attention to the cold chain.
And I realized... I had visited farms, and
I had visited factories,
and obviously I'd talked to chefs, and I had I'd even
been to the grocery store on occasion.
But I had never been inside a refrigerated warehouse.
And I'm gonna guess most of you haven't either.
And here we are in the Bay Area,
which is home of farm-to-table.
But that "to" word... it goes via
the refrigerated warehouse.
Like in between farm and table
is a giant cold space that nobody thinks about.
So I decided to explore it.
And I partnered with
the Center for Land Use Interpretation (CLUI)
which, for those of you haven't heard of it,
you are in for a treat when you Google it later.
But we mapped the American "cryosphere."
And then I still wasn't done.
So then I wrote a piece
for the New York Times Magazine that took me to China
to explore their artificial cryosphere.
And then I still wasn't done.
So I decided to sell a book on this topic
and research that and write that
and that is still not done
but that's a whole other story.
So I have gone deep into this artificial cryosphere
and my goal tonight is: let's go on a quick spin
through this space past present future.
I hope you wrapped up warmly.
We are stepping inside.
And I want to start this thing right...
with a banquet.
This in its time was the most talked about meal
in the United States.
The organizers had originally booked a small room.
They had to upgrade to the largest
banqueting hall in Chicago.
The guest list kept expanding.
A member of Congress decided they wanted to come.
Then other members of Congress
decided they wanted to come.
People were flooding this...
and so what is so special about this meal you ask?
Well this was the world's first
cold storage banquet.
Everything on the menu had been stored
under refrigeration.
Except I should point out for the olives
in the dry martini. Not refrigerated.
So this took place on Monday, October 23rd, 1911.
And there's a thousand people in the room.
White linen... full table service... the crystal is out.
The result was 2 hours of what industry journal
The Egg Reporter called "unalloyed pleasure."
And what is amazing about it
is that everything on the menu
had spent at least 6 months
and up to a year in cold storage.
And what I love about this menu too is,
again here in the Bay Area,
we are used to seeing who grew
our... this is Mary's chicken,
or this particular heirloom variety of tomato.
Do we ever see what cold storage it was in?
We do not.
Here we have Booth's Cold Storage, proud
the last address of that salmon.
And the introduction to the meal explained
your turkey that's eleven months old
your eggs (seven months)
the President of the National Poultry, Butter and Egg Association, who was giving this introduction
said "Your capon received its summons
to the great unknown last Valentine's Day,"
The pie, even the pie: cold stored flour,
butter churned in June. Apples, and this is October,
so they they could have had fresh. But, no.
They'd been in storage alongside the salmon
at Booth's for a year.
The head chef of the hotel
where this was being served, a man called Lucien, said
"There has never been a better meal
served at this hotel."
The San Antonio Express reporter said
"Nothing was quite fresh."
The president of the Poultrymen's Association
said "This is edible proof that cold stored foods
are not only good they're better
than the ones that you would eat fresh."
And the congressman
who was called upon to speak
agreed and said "Yes,
I really believe that there is more flavor
to cold storage poultry than the kind
that is advertised as freshly killed."
And he said "I'm going back to Washington.
I'm telling the folks: cold storage is where it's at."
So this kind of lunch became a national trend.
So L.A. held the next one. Then there was one in Detroit.
There was one in Philly.
2 years later there was another one in
Chicago
with literally thousands of people,
and a special three-page souvenir brochure
with not only where the food had been stored.
But also the temperature and relative humidity
of where it had been stored.
So it became a trend. And this is
barely more than a century ago.